mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wer kultur
business lust ihn viel vergnügen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sollten wir überhaupt hier sein
und die antwort lautet
ja dieses treffen ist ganz im sinne des
schweizer mittelweg
in diesem sinne augen auf und mitten
rein ins kino vergnügen zumindest die
geimpften geposteten und genießen
kulturplatz liegt offen welche filme und
themen solothurn in atem hielten
[Musik]
die filmtage sind nach einem jahr im
digitalen exil wieder vor ort real da wo
sie sein sollen in solothurn herzlich
willkommen im helvetischen hollywood und
bei kulturplatz
eva wannenmacher nina brunner sind
krankheitshalber abwesend gute besserung
von dieser stelle wegen der pandemie
waren die kinosäle hier leer im letzten
jahr die virtuelle variante konnte nicht
ganz mithalten mit den richtigen
festival feeling darum war die vorfreude
auf den eröffnungsfilm laufen heiße von
eva die tiere umso größer die
regisseurin hier kurz vor der premiere
in der reithalle hat beste erinnerungen
an solothurn eva vita hat 2016 mit ihrem
erstling das leben drehen den hauptpreis
gewonnen nun ist sie wieder da gekommen
um zu überzeugen mit einem film über die
weltberühmte krimiautorin zwischen
heißen eine frau eine schriftstellerin
die vielen als missmutige misanthropen
in erinnerung geblieben ist mit dem
neuen dokumentarfilm werden wir nun die
liebenswerte und leidenschaftliche für
smith kennen
es geht wirklich sehr unterschiedlicher
politischer heißt dass noch
große faszination aus
dass ich eine wunderschöne frau ist eben
auf dem vom leben und man krank die
vorteile von ihrer sie den alt und
vergrämt und verbietet es ist schon
wahnsinnig große loßburger bitte
britischer heißen ist und ich glaube es
ist mir nie begegnet wo so
unterschiedliche charaktere gekommen
[Musik]
wie viele andere filmemacherinnen zogen
mich die geschichten von patricia
highsmith
aber als ich ihre unveröffentlichten
tagebücher lars verliebte ich mich ein
paar tische heißt es selbst
[Musik]
ihr allererster tagebuch antrag ist
ziemlich mysteriös
[Musik]
februar
den nachlass von paar tische heißt es
verwahrt das schweizerische
literaturarchiv in bern
hier entzifferte evita monate lang die
von handgeschriebenen notiz und
tagebücher
chronologisch und
was sie las entsprach so gar nicht dem
düsteren bild das sie von der autorin
hatte
er gut mit so einer jungen ganz
lebendige
sehr
schwärmerische und romantische frau
entgegen und traviss getötet ganz andere
verhältnisse
und das ist in allem so der grundgedanke
von feeling sehe dass meine art versucht
wie die andere sieht beliebte wo man
noch nicht so ganz ins kollektive
gedächtnis eingebrannt hat sich
highsmith image einer abweisenden
außenseiterin ein bild geprägt von den
letzten jahren vor ihrem tod 1995 im
tessin
meine familie ist nach dem ja zum ferien
und und der heizkreise darunter ganz
berühmte schriftstellerin mit ganz
leicht mit ihr eine katze in einer hus
kann mich erinnert mich das damals schon
beschäftigt hat wieso warnt jetzt die
frau mit einem gruß allein mit der katze
es hat irgendwie etwas mysteriöses
beschäftigt
wonach heißt es sich sehnte
akzeptanz bedingungslose liebe
kein versteckspiel keine schuldgefühle
wegen ihrer homosexualität
der leidenschaft und dem leiden hat sich
ihrer vita angenommen damit gelingt ja
auch ein neuer blick auf reis miss merck
nicht mord sei ein thema sagte die
schriftstellerin einst sondern die
abwesenheit oder präsenz von schuld
ihre romane sind gespickt mit eigenen
erlebnissen eigenen emotionen allen
voran carroll die geschichte einer
lesbischen liebesbeziehung
2015 von todd haynes sinnlich verfilmt
als ich in einem kaufhaus in new york
arbeitete
mitten im weihnachtsstress verkaufte ich
puppen
kam eine frau im pelzmantel 1
sie war auffallend gut gekleidet
nachts schrieb ich dann das erlebnis in
notizheft
heißes schrieb carroll der verlange zeit
einzige lesbische roman mit happy ends
unter dem pseudonym clay morgen so
kannte man sie auch in den new yorker
bars
nebst archivrecherchen ging eva wie
tiere auf reisen traf drei von heißes
unzähligen geliebten
unter anderem die heute 95 jährige mary
jane michael die offiziell letzte
partnerin mit der heißen ist
zusammenlebte
[Musik]
ihre mutter habe sie mit terpentin
abtreiben wollen treffen ist
geboren wurde pat in texas
die mutter zog nach new york
lisbeth sechs jahre lang hat ihren
großmutter
es ist meine russ aufwachsen in texas wo
die vordere reihe bücher sind für die
sexy und die hintere reihe füße sind
viele schwarze sitze negro erließ das
ist aber jetzt kommen und gäbe es sie
dass es immer hinter der hauptstraße
gibt es nur bei micro rna
anderen aber das ist ja keine stadt
fotos vorsorge liszt zentrum für die
cowboys ist das einfach total gbk sie
und was macht es mit der person
herkunft fehlende mutterliebe ihre
homosexualität die sie für ihre mutter
sogar zu kurieren versuchte führten zur
verbitterung
gras
wiederholt äußerte sich die autorin mit
zunehmendem alter rassistisch
antisemitisch
in wickie us film spielt dieses medial
heiß diskutierte thema eine nebenrolle
ihre antisemitische züge sind ganz klar
wieso es vorteile habe mich sehr
beschäftigt also ich finde das ist eine
sehr abgestoßen hat oder britischer
heißt es du musst
ja weil wir von der hand man muss jetzt
auch dem anderen thema von einem
versteckten jetzt einfach mal in ruhe
das ist wahrlich mehr platz zum verzehr
bis jetzt das thema das tier tv bilder
das ist immer noch ein abgrund geht
hinter der oberfläche oder das geht klar
definiert die identität hat alles was
wir zum beispiel in betrieb sind zudem
wolfgang sehr stark von dem lehrer bis
sie sind nein er ist sehr nett
also bitte er
du findest jeden etwas
seelische abgründe
doppelbödigkeit waren teil ihrer selbst
das wird im film spürbar liebe sichtbar
ihr liebesleben wenn auch im versteckten
kostete reißaus
das muss immer mehr verliert und und so
schwärmt und ich
finde das alles lasse das ist wie wenn
sich direkt begegnet weil sechs jahre
lang hatte evita allawis gearbeitet
ist äußerst feinfühlig und einfühlsam
mit dem nachlass der bestseller-autorin
umgegangen
beschönigt nichts klagt aber auch nicht
an
wie tier zeichnet ein schicksalhaftes
leben nach und gibt einer generation von
frauen eine stimme die für ihre liebe
kämpfen
[Musik]
loving highsmith hat das publikum hier
begeistert in der gunst der jury stand
aber ein ganz anderer film zuoberst
neulich in einem dorf am schwarzen meer
soeben hat sich erhängt denn jeder zu
kennen glaubte um die beerdigung zu
organisieren wird dessen enkelin gerufen
sie lernt ihren opa posthum neu kennen
indem sie sein verborgenes show das
liebesleben entdeckt sowie ein geflecht
von lügen dass die dorfgemeinschaft auf
tragische weise einzuengen scheint
können
der prix de soleure geht an die sf
koproduktion mit sense der gebürtigen
georgierin elene avriani
das drama der 36-jährigen das bereits in
locarno gefeiert wurde kann sich im
rennen um den schweizer filmpreis
hoffnungen auf eine weitere wichtige
auszeichnung machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier im restaurant kreuz ist eigentlich
immer hochbetrieb werden des festivals
aber wegen kubik bleibt die obere etage
gesperrt gut für uns dann haben wir viel
raum für das gespräch mit dem neuen
leitungsteam der filmtage marien wird
damit wohl auf die premiere als co
leiter wurf der solothurner filmtage
ja sehr gut wir sind sehr glücklich
besetzt so lotto sind die großen
drastisch wieder ins kino zu
begegnen und film auf der großen und
ganzen also wie viele kunden tatsächlich
umgesetzt
also begeben werden 50 prozent und für
zuschauer in die augen augen auf eine
normale gründliche jahr und das magazin
ist
bisher passiert ist letzterer ist damit
der fünfte ihre vorgängerin tisch
abgesetzt worden sie selber seit märz
ihr eigentlich hinter ihren drucker ins
machte den filmtagen 70 vertreter mit
dem ganzen team wie hängt sie zwei die
situationen erlebt
also was macht eigentlich
natürlich haben wir die schwierige
situation für alle beteiligten
aber das stört liege über der konflikt
report worte und insofern nicht
mehr dazu sagen und es ist ja auch eine
punkt einfach wichtig sieht dass man aus
dem tag reichen morgen ich bin am alex
reid ich bin ich auch schon solothurner
sommer event vom organisiert vom
filmverband und für einer frau netzwerk
der kaiser mercy anita und tonic merkt
ganz viele der branche sind
eben der stimmt und motiv standen wird
das abklopfen ist und wie wird das
wunder nehmen was sie dazu wissen sieger
zu gerne zu einer reaktion aber immer
mehr gesammelt hätten
mögen sie sich erinnern was ihr fahrer
hin dass die theologie gott was ist
ihnen da durch den kopf gegangen ich bin
sehr irritiert sie
ja das ist medien erfahren also und
gleich ein schneller fahrer und das ist
eigentlich babys hat mich angestarrt was
genau passiert ist aber wie vor mit die
zusätzliche ebene über videos wie das
verheizt worden ist das ist das ist
wirklich das ist schädlich für solothurn
filmtag das ist schädlich für den etat
das ist eigentlich für die schweizer
fehlen können sie die kritik verstehen
willst du komisch
also ich verstehe dass das vergessen
natürlich sicher sehr abrupt wirkt hat
das kann ich nachvollziehen das
ist also das türkei kommunikation
stattgefunden
was sind sie denn verantworte wo sie
heute branche können sie den rhythmus
sorgen machen
ja das muss ich das mache ich mein
netzwerk
organisiert profis sind das system der
kinderstadt dass kontinuität gibt und
dass es funktioniert dass es läuft also
verwenden und jeder fan film kb das ja
auch mit extrem viel geist cover rosen
und friedberg ich sehr gut aus ich
glaube da muss man sich keine sorgen
machen tag an dem alles ist einheitlich
stil präsentiert wollte mit dem edwin
schmitt idee mutter nicht der umgebung
gesetzt wo man jetzt unbedingt wird
baute das würde deren kurzzeit
fordern der wunschliste was wünschen sie
sich denn also mir wünsche ist sicher
das hat die zukünftige leitung ein
intensives durchsucht mit der
filmbranche dass er die zukünftig ein
hoher sensibilität für alle fragen von
diversity also vor allem im bereich
zentralen bereichen sprachregionen der
schweiz haben wir morgen wird wenn sie
zu können
was geht ihnen durch den kopf was
verdienen
wünsche für den ford clique setzen sie
jetzt
nach danksin wünsche im werk
asset-klasse sind also musst du stark
es war mir schon flackert die dass die
sowieso also machen sie das zum beispiel
im filmprogramm und ganz für
filmproduzent in karatschi die visite
institution also besuchte
geschäftsstelle wirtschaft mehr frauen
als männer ist der einzig marc sie also
was ist erfüllt und im filmprogramm logo
wirklich aus erster gruppe
solle
die geschäfte betreibt
vorstandsebene sich heftig
insofern muss ich selbstverständlichen
und wird auch in zukunft
sehr verachtet werden
nicht nur jetzt für jedes festival
wichtig sondern wahrscheinlich für alle
vielen festivals wer kriegt man einen
schritt zurück ins kino ich glaube es
gab wie mocken vermittelt und zwar
wirklich vor ganz ohne
und dann kann auch das kinopublikum
zukunft
gewährleistet die frage wer die leute
ins kino kommen wie die videos zu kriegt
das hätte auch besuche in einem suche
der insolventen festival beschäftigt
wann waren sie das letzte mal im kino
das ist der letzte film taxi vor einem
jahr
dem
trio minimum
ja willi nichts ohne große kino gabi
grundsätzlich erwarte forscher jetzt für
die spielfilme war die ab dieser
reihenfolge
wann erwartet das letzte mal im kino
warum waren sie so lange nicht im kino
ja es ist möglich sie und dem torhüter
premiere ist doch schön und wie haben
sie die zeit überbrückt jetzt die 2
streamen entdeckt
gegen jetzt wieder zurück locken vom
sofa ins kino
wenn die maus krechel
solothurn
2021 im dritten jahr der pandemie kehrt
das publikum zurück an die aare nicht in
strömen dennoch fühlen sich hier und da
die seele
in den kinos hingegen schrumpfen die
publikumszahlen kontinuierlich seit 20
jahren bestätigt erde im karademir vom
bundesamt für statistik die viren machen
es noch schlimmer gute zweimonatlich
pandemie k und d pads sowieso nie
bruchsal kino ii tritt er aber wieder
anzahl vorstellungen und der firma wo
gestartet sind
im 2020 heizen heizen rückgang auf rund
46 prozent im vergleich zum juni also
vor der pandemie und
die provisorische 20 21 die zuvor rund
5,5 millionen
kino ii tritt das ist immer noch
wesentlich
tiefer als vor der pandemie was also tun
damit streaming dienste und pandemien
die große leinwand nicht aus unserem
leben verdrängen in solothurn ist die
frage wie man das publikum bei der
stange halten kann allgegenwärtig einer
der gäste könnte eine antwort haben der
st galler architekt peter hutter denn er
bot kinos mir entwickelt architektur wo
man sich wohlfühlt aber fraglich warum
verschiedenen sache gesehen oder auf dem
sofa nicht erlebt das heißt im kino beim
publikums bis wohl provoziert wo wofür
sie elemente wo frisch sind wo man sich
daheim nicht leistet
was auf den ersten blick nicht unbedingt
produziert sondern wie ein ganz normales
kino aussieht zumindest im innenraum
kann mehr als es vorgibt es eignet sich
für andere veranstaltungen ebenso wie
fürs filme streamen wie sie bauherren
bauherr wünsche architekturen wo nicht
nur reine funktion tendieren sondern
sprechen vor allem auszuruhen könnens
und verschiedene darstellen die
integrierte
filmförderung chef ivo kummer sieht das
ähnlich und fordert mehr aus kino zu
machen als nur filmkunst vorzuführen ein
paar ideen bringt er gleich selber mit
also ich bin optimistisch das gericht
wird iris kinowelt
gothic das iphone oder film zeige und
topcu und verkauf tätig dort rekord
zukunft nicht sondern den kinos eurozone
hat nichts wie hin ob suche nach den
event deshalb stand der bericht dass man
zum beispiel premiere gemacht mit der
filmcrew mit max das ist möglich zu
finden wenn man live konzert
solche events finden auch in biel im
kino rex stadt
als allheilmittel gegen zuschauerschwund
stuft kinobetreiberin etwa applebaum die
eventisierung jedoch nicht ein
die inflation wird forscher auf dem
event oma chronik logemann ich muss
meinen kaffee um dabei den event einfach
den platz laufe trübt einfach ruhiger
ohne diskussion ohne geld ohne glamour
sondern hälfte liter möglich krebs café
oder im privaten
die diskussion ums publikum klingt für
applebaum die das familienunternehmen in
dritter generation führt höchst
vertraute dokument vor der 50-jährige
ist das schädliche diskussion sie die
konkurrenz der verein sechs sie jetzt
ist konkurrenz streaming ich glaube das
publikum ist toll ich glaube es wird das
kinopublikum immer gar mit krampf im
letzten jahr für das publikum kampf wenn
der inhalt gut ist dann muss man sich ok
angst machen weil jungen publikum mit
thomas
wette mehr erinnern erzählt
filmproduzent erich bisher will sich
mehr auf die wünsche des publikums
konzentrieren auch für ihn am
wichtigsten die qualität
vor allem gute filme filme die das
publikum wirklich interessiert
wenn man die plakate hier unter mir in
solothurn hand schaut sieht man ein kino
das vor allem auf die bedürfnisse von
den leuten die filme produzieren
fokussiert und nicht auf die nachfrage
spielers meinung nach könnte die lecks
netflix eine lösung sein das gesetz
sieht vor dass die tv-sender und
streaming dienste in die schweizer
filmbranche investieren müssen nun kommt
die vorlage aber fußvolk die
jungparteien von fdp svp und glp haben
letzte woche circa 70.000 unterschriften
für das referendum eingereicht
der schweizer film hat ein
angebotsproblem da ist lex netflix eine
sehr gute und wichtige idee um diesem
problem entgegenzuwirken
auch wenn dabei ein die streaming
plattformen reinvestiert wird wird es
einen positiven einfluss auf die
kinoproduktion haben
die leute die das referendum eingereicht
haben und behaupten damit die
konsumenten zu schützen sind demagogen
weil ex netflix die vielfalt vergrößern
und endlich genau das erreichen wird was
bereits vor 20 jahren gefordert wurde
dass mehr populäres kino produziert wird
das publikum zurück zu gewinnen ist das
große anliegen der branche
das betrifft neben den solothurner
filmtagen
kinobetreibern produzenten und die
politik vor allem das publikum selbst
hat euch das kino geht in der partei
allerdings ab
nun freuen wir uns sehr heute hier zu
sein und
streaming
wobei ich hab ich das jetzt grün
muss nach stetig hat jetzt
das hat jetzt wieder mehr ins kino das
dass ich zu jung
[Musik]
si
macht doch
das event findet ist das eigentlich
wahnsinnig viel filmclub wird also zu
netflix zeiten jede lockte den fehler
begehen wäre oder noch lehrer nach der
schule jede lobby wird er fehlen direkt
als kino gehabt irgendwie vor sich hin
aber der junge zu beliebten sie das
gefühl
es könnte daran liegt dass man wird so
der schweizer taste zu der generation
die
meiste für netflix gelockt werden sie
hat immer noch hinauf aber droge schaut
wo das sie läuft werden und
ein großer teil
der art forum schafft
im kino sahen die jungen der tat bringt
also das muss irgendwie verbindet mit
dem sprach mit der
diskussionsrunde oder
wenn man so möchte die junge reich
gemacht nur diskussion durch das nicht
des kratzers ich glaube geschichte oder
content ich dass ich immer genau wie ihr
seid das ist immer wie so was wohl alle
menschen ansprechen die universelle
menschliche geschichte und das ist wie
der junge menschen nicht anders
verändert sich schnell wurde mir
ganz gut aber auch damit trug die der
filmgeschichte werden eine lösung zum
beispiel für sie von der saturn 5 das
ist ein
film zeige für junge filmemacherinnen
und filmemacher
ja das waren also junge kennt ihn ja als
einem jahr wieder abrufen fehlen für
junge zeigt das wird's richtig wild
pause aber das wird in der
jahresproduktion lorca und selektioniert
nach qualitativen kriterien ganz mutig
und das wird quasi unterschiede zwischen
der altersklasse aber nein der
wirklichkeit so explizit für die jungen
studenten
warum arbeitet bereits elexxion ihren
einfluss canino einzig der esskultur
instagram kanal abonniert sie
jetzt fragen was mit der ehrlichen
schülerin irgendwas
machen sie dass es lohnt sich
aktuelle kulturgeschichte womit wir
zeigen mini kollegin avs werkhof
instagram sind ziemlich überzeugt vom
neuen werk von regisseurin opel hölzl
und fördere slam poetin lauda stelle
ich bin lara stoll ich bin dass sie über
unser unternehmen ist ein zweiter film
gemacht er heißt
die konfitüre gekauft
ja aber sind in deutschen kinos ist auch
um die sagen ja es geht ein charakter
der ist basierend auf berlin.de online
content creation so youtube und so
hatten green screen and ride plätze in
youtube löscher will das macht und der
algorithmus fängt das nicht gut für
youtube
aha so fehlen wo man machine die meisten
ist mamiweb das und sich und mit ruß und
und das ist vielleicht weniger schlecht
gehen wir machen sind aber es gibt in
lübbecke das und die renten nicht
erklären wieso dass es gut wenn man eine
frau aus olivenholz etwas gar dass gott
um liebe um was ist lustig es
geht um
unnötig frei
[Musik]
vorurteil da gibt es ja die frau maria
die afrikaner und es passiert das ist
gut denn eigentlich um kraft und braun
und dagegen nur heilige hochzeit am
schluss
[Musik]
ja es ist
bekannt
dass ich es nicht für mich
ich glaube es berührt einem also das
macht bis
zuletzt filme gemacht haben hat mich zum
suizid geraten nachdem die film gesehen
hat
[Musik]
viel erreichen
und es ist ja und rechte actionfilm
worte
strengen die dreharbeiten
das sind ja nicht einfach irgendwie sie
dialog und und das verpflegungszelt
sondern es sind immer auch
extremsituationen extrabreiten und dazu
stehe ich immer solistisch und und
sadistisch beiden
seiten
[Musik]
basta
das war es von den 57 solothurner
filmtagen in einem film eintauchen das
kann man immer noch am besten im kino
das gilt übrigens auch für horrorfilme
die sollen ja im moment wieder voll im
trend seien eva wannenmacher weiß mehr
nächste woche bei uns
direkt im anschluss trifft philosophie
auf comedy barbara gleichtakt mit viel
club recht in der sternstunde ich
wünsche gute unterhaltung und sage bis
bald bei kultur
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
tourismus
[Applaus]